so I think we have a tendency to
personalize power to see power in the
manifestation of individuals and I
believe that the concept is much deeper
much more abroad than that for example
there are many kinds of power there's a
economic power political power military
morale and so forth and so on I think
that we tried to often simplify these
ideas and again this turning power into
a person or seeing a person in making
that emblematic of of power has not
changed power is the capacity of one
individual or organization to get
another individual organization to do or
stop doing something so that has not
changed
what has changed deeply profoundly is
the sources of power the way power is
exerted the where power is constrained
the way power is gained and lost in the
21st century power has become easier to
acquire harder to use and easier to lose
and you see a lot of examples that the
describe of Facebook and all Google boys
really think that they can lose their
power you know if we have this
conversation five years ago we will not
be talking about Microsoft we will be
talking about Microsoft rather now we're
talking about Google and Facebook five
years ago we will talk deep talking and
everybody was worried about Microsoft so
all I'm saying is of course these are
very I'm not denying that they are very
powerful centers of power all I'm saying
is that power is becoming more fleeting
is that they are there's more
constrained and you know we see constant
rotations in the in those who help power
power is becoming less permanent and so
you asked where is power today and it's
everywhere there is far more centers of
power centers of veto that limit what
the main players can do
than in the past my position is much
easier because the best ways to define
power is when you don't have it and from
this point you the Bulgarian position is
good
we never abuse power but but but I'll
try to make just three very brief points
first is on what you were reading in
Warren piece because this is part of the
Western dilemma you have Kenya's
Bolkonsky being there somebody who is
fascinated with the idea of the French
Revolution and Napoleon but he is
fighting him being conversion officer so
from this point of view the fact that
somebody is going to be influenced by
you does not mean that he's going to be
on the same Army with you and from this
point the very idea that democratization
of the world is going to end up in the
pro-western world in my view was one of
the major illusions that people are
talking about everything that you see in
a certain way is the result of the
democratization of the world but
different people secondly and from it
this is also quite important you have
two different ways to try to deal with
power one is to pretend that you are
more powerful than you are and it's a
classic authoritarian game you pretend
that you control everything knowing very
well that you don't but now you start to
see in the democracies the opposite game
now the democratic governments govern by
pretending that they're much weaker than
they are if you basically talk to the
Democratic politicians these days
they're competing to tell you that they
cannot do anything I cannot do this
before the market I cannot do this
before of the courts and so on and to be
honest part of the support for the
populist parties come to the fact they
said we want something quickly says that
he can do something and I do believe
this is quite important because this
also explains and this is my third and
last point on this why the conspiracy
theories I saw spreading all over people
don't have the feeling that they know
where power is because power is not
where it used to be so you say okay if
the governments are so weak where is the
power is it Facebook or is it something
else and technically from this point if
there is
story the world is not transparent and
it used to be but as a result of it the
conspiracy theories are basically
spreading better so probably there is
nothing more suspicious than
transparency of power the individual is
more powerful than it was but exactly
because he is more powerful than it is
at least in the Western world the
collective action is much more difficult
because you have the feeling that you
can make a change without needing others
and this is why people whom you're going
to see on the street protesting against
something and not the same people who
are going to vote on the elections
paradoxically we have this big protest
in Bulgaria some years ago and the major
demand was new elections but 60% of the
people who asked for new elections they
said they're not going to vote for them
because there is nobody to vote for and
this is part of this paradox of
empowerment which is not producing the
kind of a much more democratic society I
feel that the Europeans have limited
themselves both politically and and
militarily and they have had a
relationship of dependence with the
United States I do believe that they can
lead again I'm with you on that one they
can lead again and they must if if the
United States is where it is now but I
want to move from here to actually the
Middle East and talk about power over
there where those who govern are scared
of those whom they govern and those who
are governed are scared from the people
who govern them so who has power for
many many years the Arab world behaved
like an abused child however it has no
trust and in itself or confidence in the
others it's basically the result of many
years of of colonialism but also because
after being brutalized under colonialism
you had a you were they were brutalized
by their own leadership it's a
leadership that is brutal but not
powerful they are in fact their weakness
is translated into
brutality but I think the uprisings have
at least for for people from the Middle
East and the Arab world it has we had no
hope at least now we have hope when you
talk about this uncertainty about the
power in the West it indeed has to do
with shift of power in the world from
the West to the rest notably China and
if we talk about the power in terms of
soft power and hard power what you see
clearly what I call a shift of paradigm
shift from the so-called
democracy versus autocracy to good
governance was it good bad governance
says what China advocates good
governments can take form a Western
political system there are some cases
not always good governance can also take
the form of non-western political system
Chinese is an example where many
problems but overwhelming speaking it's
far more positive than negative
mr. levy today you said something that
first of all again you inspired me to
look at behaviors in the world and to
think about what we have done and failed
to do it could do but you used the term
many times and you said everyone knows I
have to relate a personal experience
when I retired from the military and I
spent a year in academia I was struck by
a similar term being used by a number of
professors or lecturers and the term
that I heard quite frequently was you
know and after hearing this for a while
as soon as I heard the term I used to
tense a bit because often what followed
wasn't what I knew and
it wasn't what I had seen and in some
cases I'd actually been there and seen
that in some cases done it so I was
really little put off of this but the
point is that I believe we we have our
own visions all of us each of us as
human beings of what's going on and one
of the challenges for those who would
aspire to power to use it in good ways
is the reality that you need to in my
opinion get people to buy into the idea
that you're trying to do something and
hopefully you're doing it for the good
how about the number of sorts of powers
this is the real real question there is
the power of visual you can bag and the
power of mr. Khan but what the modern
philosophy the philosophy of the last
decades did teach us Michel Foucault for
example name is familiar everybody knows
I'm sorry can I say that if that this
hell Foucault said that the power has no
place no place that there is no single
source of power that there is something
which he calls bio power bio power and
which is spread disseminated all over
the society embedded in the very flesh
of the language in the very flesh of the
society in the very blood of the desire
uniting or crane misunderstanding
between human beings men and women women
a man is also the source of power is
absolutely disseminated and you have a
book a great book of a man who is not my
political friend called Tony in a Greek
Italian agree initial article Empire
where he said common he said to the
anti-imperialist common America
imperialist joke China a new empire joke
no the
real empire is a sort of network of
micro powers which makes the real Empire
you